let's start with the topic of clients
ciance leadership are there any tips
that you can share in this regard sure
uh I think first of all never start a
project without a clear and aligned
project definition if you don't align
with your client beforehand you might
run into misunderstandings and
inefficiencies in the project and in the
end and disappointments both on the
client but also on the team side and so
I always suggest to really discuss
fundamental aspects like what's the
actual objective of a project what's the
scope what are the tasks and
deliverables of the consulting firms uh
really write things down and make it
explicit uh that that everyone is
aligned